[Music]
you know you love them it's hard
[Music]
thank you it's good to be here at the
creek in the cave for other people a
dating show where we make people date
whether they want to or not
thanks so much for coming uh with me the
dating expert Hans Kim I've been on many
dates before and I've had even sex
so I can help you guys
okay uh my name is Hans Kim just got
back from London England the motherland
and now I talk like this
um yeah I'm uh I'm I'm really jet-lagged
I'm really tired so uh yeah my jokes
might be a little bit ironic you guys
might not get it because of my British
sensibilities
the queen
whatever
uh if you're a woman
a woman have signed up if you're a man
wait is are these all men
we got too many men
then someone you're gonna have to take
yourselves out of the dating pool
and the gene pool why don't you go kill
yourself you [ __ ] useless
man here's another man to sign up that's
just what we need
hello sir would you like to identify as
a woman today
hell yeah this guy goes both ways
he sucks and he receives
um but yes we need more women any women
want to sign up please
okay pleading never works with the
ladies I've learned I'm begging you
please sign up
any women would you like to sign up
anyone coming up everyone's in a
relationship
looks like an Abercrombie and Fitch ad
right now walking through
very beautiful people
hopefully your F1 races go well today
God damn whites
strings we got all the straight males
you could want
uh and then here's another
we got a game in in the front
oh my God this table is
really really in the front and center of
things hopefully this guy can uh gather
up some females to sign up
hell yeah
one guy's enthusiastic about it
hopefully he's very convincing but uh as
usual I have a guest on this show to
help me uh guide the dates through and
provide funny quips and also give you
helpful dating advice a man who is not
only sexy but funny a comedian please
get up for the man Jordan Shelby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to 1049 the smooth jazz station
thank you a man's putting his name in
the woman's bucket
can we just do gay dates on some gay
dates guys we're gonna force people to
be gay tonight
hell yeah this is Biden's America
everyone's gay today
oh my God look at this guy he's got one
for each bucket oh this guy's going
crazy
hell yeah
he voted for Biden seven times signed up
for 14 different people
how's your dating life in general
it's good this is exactly like kill Tony
how you just asked him about who they're
[ __ ] and they're like all right get
off stage exactly this complete rip-off
of a show that's way more successful
when like I haven't asked you about
Europe did you yeah your material work
perfectly or did you have to change like
elevator to lift and stuff yeah to
change uh NASCAR to Formula One
I had to change uh you know if he said
[ __ ] did you have to say bloody [ __ ]
I had to change Mexicans to Africans
uh
yeah I couldn't do my LA Fitness joke
they don't have La fitnesses over there
I think they're defunct
you know I thought LA Fitness was a
Mexican gym because I thought it was
pronounced LA Fitness
it would have been super well received
If Only They had that gym and Mexicans
and bl Fitness
the L Fitness L Fitness no confusion
yeah yeah that one's just for Mexicans
this show is just for Mexicans and
straight males
apparently so we're gonna go ahead and
get this started hopefully some females
sign up later on we got one gay man in
the bucket stop calling them females
female identifying I don't like it when
you say female we got some
XX chromosomes
that's worse we got Daniel a straight
man coming up Daniel he put his hand on
his chest as if to say Deery me
and one of his friends Lacey
Lacey you're gonna [ __ ] Daniel tonight
[Music]
straight women
[Music]
please sign up
Daniel
and Lacey a friend of his
a friend of his girlfriend
going on a date for one minute starting
right so we just pretend like we're on a
date you are on a date okay
hello hi
how are you I'm doing well how are you
good a little nervous
well you were just at my house yeah I
know so
it was a lovely evening
we got a minute
um
so
did you like dinner I did you did that's
good
me too
[Laughter]
we probably have like 30 more seconds so
we can just sit in silence if you want
we could
um
yeah you were you were
you brought dessert I brought dessert I
got cannolis they were really nice they
were good yeah
the steak was good too yeah
yeah steak was good
I mean they're not dishes oh yeah
great first date it was great steak
cannolis dishes got done yeah we both
had our end time give it up for Lacey
we're gonna talk to you guys now why
don't you go ahead and take a seat again
Lacey you're not out of the woods yet I
have to stay you're still on the show no
you're you're here too you're both
you're both gonna sit down that's how
horny they were after that day dude they
couldn't even wait they're like we need
to [ __ ] right now where is the broom
closet
so uh
Daniel yes couldn't even last a minute
huh no is that how you how it usually
goes your cannoli
cannoli runs out of steam after about 12
seconds sometimes I like that he called
for a minute of Silence like so like
someone died
and they were being respectful to open
the date Daniel what an activist he's
calling for a minute of silence for him
he's very Masa amini Iranian woman that
died anyways
um you've already been at her house
which is a risky move in the dating
world that's all known as stalking yeah
yes how do you guys know each other well
uh I'm friends with her boyfriend wow so
it makes it even more Awkward yeah or
hotter yeah
have you ever been in a wife swap
situation Daniel
swap a Rooney how did he know the
nickname if he's never been in the
situation before
you're acting like you've been there
before no I haven't
yeah
what a vanilla boring sex life what's
the
what's the craziest thing you've done
sexually
hmm
I would have to think about that left
hand no you don't dude
you know immediately
yeah if you've done it you would know
yeah
what do you think this guy's candy a
hand job whoa is this guy the oldest
looking 14 year old ever
where did you get a hand job
I mean I've had a couple hand jobs
before you what okay yes but where where
in the car
in at home
by myself that's masturbation yeah
what about Lacy
Lacey is an innocent victim of your
futile attempts to [ __ ] her yeah it was
bad yeah the car and a house that's like
PRI the Family Feud answers yeah where
you're most likely to get a hand job and
sounds like he's masturbating yeah
giving it to yourself or are you giving
or receiving these handjobs giving
you're giving handjobs to do receive it
it was a joke
sign up for the wrong bucket
yeah
yeah one of those old the old gooferonis
over there
try to set you up with his friend's
girlfriend
Lacey uh how did you meet your boyfriend
CrossFit
CrossFit holy [ __ ] that's the most
Millennial answer ever is there anything
that Daniel could do to one-up your
boyfriend and get this date
probably not a hand job even if you did
like
Lacey with the zingers
this is how you're supposed to date man
just make sexual references
how was uh how was the steak medium rare
medium rare definitely just like just
like Daniel's hand jobs
they're rarely given
um that's cool so uh how do you how does
how do they know each other your
boyfriend and Daniel
um friend group just the guys yeah yeah
you guys go paddle boarding together
I don't know
a little circle jerk
is your girlfriend here Daniel or yes oh
my God you guys are all shacked up with
each other yeah well we thought it was
the dating show it is so yeah that's why
we all came with our spouses just real
friends
boyfriends oh [ __ ] why haven't you asked
her your girlfriend to marry you yet
yeah Daniel I'm not ready for that
Daniel everyone's waiting would you like
to on this show that's live stream to
YouTube no would you like to pop the
question no
okay sorry to Daniel's girlfriend but no
he does not want to marry you
just just today not today just today
yeah maybe tomorrow
um yeah that's an interesting this is an
interesting couple they're both already
in a relationship they came to a dating
show to look at other single people and
gloat yeah pretty yeah I didn't think
about it like that but
what's uh her your boyfriend's in
CrossFit
so even if this guy does like more
push-ups or like can
paint pull-ups yeah
that wouldn't that wouldn't win him over
I don't think there's any way I could do
more pull-ups than John
wow John sounds like a stud
is he the one that signed you all up
with his forearm strength yeah he's like
no none no one can beat me up anyways
let me just sign them up
that's cool so you guys have a cool
little friend group you guys do things
together eat steak and hang out at
Lacey's house yeah
what else do you guys do together
hand jobs
I don't know I know Daniel doesn't know
anything he never has sex
he never does fun things with his
awesome friend groups
what's your job man what do you do me I
work in advertising I'm actually crazy
that we don't know that after the minute
of them yeah finding out about each
other you guys didn't talk about the one
thing you do the most in life yeah I
didn't listen to him either what'd you
just say it was I do
um media like advertising
can you think you get some more people
out to the show Maybe
maybe you could advertise yourself to
Lacey yeah if you had to write a tagline
for yourself sexually what would it be
oh man
[ __ ] Central yeah I don't know
okay he's gonna get fired soon he's not
good at his job Lacey I would stick with
John yeah
I think he's about to be homeless with
his girlfriend
Lacey what do you do for a living
um financial services oh gosh she has a
better job than you bro yeah
she's bringing it home the bacon
so uh what would you advise
uh Daniel financially to do
they know very well enough to advise you
yeah okay the story is getting weird
here all of a sudden
this is the worst porno ever
I'm in advertising ultimate Financial
Services it's very exciting
well we only have one other woman uh
would you like to go on a date with
another man Lacey
that's a yes do I have a choice no
particularly you're half the show you're
gonna be up here 45 minutes
uh give it up for Daniel
here's a savior to help Lacey out
I got a man with a very beautiful shirt
like I saw that shirt in Garden State
um but thank you for signing up sir
we got a woman coming up Lacey
is no more which one will it be Lacey is
signed up twice in the straight man
bucket
oh for her oh you're signing up a woman
hopefully you asked for consent
with that shirt I doubt it
uh but we got AK coming up the person
that just signed up
thank you for signing up AK immediate
Returns on investment just like Lacey's
Financial Services
and we got a straight man coming up
who will it be what are the desperate
horny men we have Howard
yeah
oh word
it's like a frat energy over there
chuck chuck we got AK and Howard thank
you for signing up
AK
a
gotta keep the humor going
one minute of dating from Howard The
Reluctant Bachelor and AKA thrilled to
be here thrilled to be here one minute
starting now
I'm good how are you can you hear me
hi I'm from San Antonio Texas
that's all right I feel the same way
I work here in Austin
so I work in mental health
very interesting
so where are you from
I am from Boston I moved to Austin about
three years ago put the mic right by
your chin thank you oh
yeah
just like your boyfriend pretend it's
his [ __ ]
I am from Boston I've been in Austin for
about three years now
can you hear me now
great all right there we go the audience
please let them date
okay so you moved here from Boston
correct for work for fun for fun okay
and what was your name one more time ak
ak okay I can remember that
I'm sure you can't but you remember my
name nope
I was too busy with thinking about how
I'm gonna say my name so okay yeah and
time give it up for this lovely couple
they actually asked each other questions
and got to know each other novel concept
take notes Daniel
so you said San Antonio and then aka you
said I'm sorry
what do you hate about San Antonio
nothing
no fool around this time this time you
just are apologetic for him having been
from there
AKA that's an interesting name is are
you named after the gun
exactly
or Alaska it's the abbreviation for
Alaska
which one do you think
well I think that you are a rapid fire
and
hot to the touch so so definitely Alaska
Alaska it is for sure and you have lots
of crafts no just kidding uh thank you
for signing up AKA we uh we want to
preserve our natural resource that is
our dwindling supply of straight females
yes
do you have any questions for this
lovely uh
Better Home and Garden couple
yeah you said you moved to a city for
fun
what is that mean
there's like I'm gonna quit my job and
go have fun
in a different city it means I'm gonna
break up with my boyfriend and go rage
somewhere else and dye my hair
this is good news this is good news for
him
this is good news for him Howard yo
she's like I'm gonna go [ __ ] in this new
city yeah she's ready to she's DTF yeah
sounds like it well you don't have a lot
of sex do you
[Music]
I don't know
you got enough he's there for it
he seems like he's afraid maybe he
believes in Jesus maybe he's in a
relationship already it seems like
everyone over there is shacked up
which one is it Howard both are true
oh he's a Jesus Freak it's a Jesus flag
personally but you know that's just his
hands they're bloody from dying for your
sins AKA well someone's
almost
um AKA what is your religion of choice
no no what was the question what's well
I wanted to know ak's religion oh I want
you so you're an atheist now exactly
there you go exactly
Howard uh so your your girlfriend is
with you right over there in that table
yes she is and uh are you just trying
not to get yelled at tonight no I don't
think no I'm just having a good time
oh I'd hate to see you having a bad time
me too
what
what do you like to do for fun I like
hanging out with most of those people
well all of those people at the table
whoa most of those people most he said
most interesting answer house which one
of these people would you kick out if
you had the choice
probably Lacy Lacey
no I'm just I'm just John's about to do
a pull up on your ass I know right it's
about to CrossFit you into the next bar
yes
that's cool Lacey's the only other
person I know besides Daniel so
the way she's the one that I know the
least so oh that was an honest answer
that's an honest answer I don't
understand this Dynamic group of friends
who don't know each other very well
they were like we're in the same tax
bracket yeah
let's all hang out together during the
f1s Race season
are you watching F1 or do you just look
like a race car driver no I'm just I'm
not into the F1 stuff
so you're more into dtf1
dtf1 down to [ __ ] one down to [ __ ] one
yes yes
as a correct answer your girlfriend just
left you
because you're down to [ __ ] one yep
uh so uh maybe we should ask her what
makes him
so it's so dateable
Maybe
maybe we should see why Howard is maybe
she can vouch for him
uh Howard's girlfriend what makes Howard
so dateable
he's down to [ __ ] one and only one
person and that's Jesus Christ could be
there's no room in his relationships
for a [ __ ] that's gross
son yes
[Music]
what a beautiful man I can't wait to see
you on uh a dating show a talk show like
uh
NBC Nightly News yeah well thank you
you're welcome thank you
AK what do you think makes Howard so
dateable this fall he seems very honest
yeah he said like three words so far
exactly he's a man of a few words but
honest words honest words of
yeah what about Hobbies you guys got any
hobbies
in common or not
alcohol
this girl's fun
she's down to alcohol
who has time for hobbies
a lot of people
I like I like surfing skateboarding yeah
I like stuff like that
surfing and skateboarding I like surfing
yeah a lot of great it's hot yeah do you
already have a girlfriend relax dude
all right you find a lot you catch a lot
of good waves on ladybird Lake yeah
no San Antonio and uh Austin not really
known for their surfing you ever go to
Waco yeah I've been to the surf Park in
Waco have you done it before yeah
I think Jordan wants to go on a date
with
Howard Jordan's a good looking guy too
yeah hell yeah I like the show what
about me
no you're a good looking guy too
everyone's catching compliments but the
host this is my show I can cancel it at
any time
AK are you here with your boyfriend over
there I'm with the date oh hell yeah how
many dates have you guys been on this is
our first date wow that's a risky move
she could leave you right now at any
moment okay
how did you guys meet
oh oh
that's hot is it yeah
I want to ask him a question but it's
not time for that all right oh you want
us in the bucket don't worry you want to
ask ak's hinge date a question yeah
Zach
you look like Alex Jones from over here
it's yeah
yeah maybe when he gets up here
well we'll have to wait till it gets
called up I'm sure he will there's I
think there's one more female that we
can
look at mine
uh so that's cool you guys are both sort
of occupied but on a date together
what uh what do you think you guys would
do together let me go to Sephora he
could hold your hand back I think he'd
be good at that it's very quiet type
yeah I don't know if I'd pick Sephora
I'm more of an Ulta girl but you know
you're talking about makeup oh my God he
knows I know
what a Lucky Gal
he knows about your [ __ ]
so AKA uh What uh what brought you out
tonight with your hinge day what made
you want to go on a dating show with a
date
gets me out and I said yes oh hell yeah
so he's the one that wants to swing
around he's the DTF for sure oh nice
that's how you know
let's go on a dating show because
that'll Lube us up
Loom us
Jordan let's get lubed
Luber up that's the catchphrase on this
show
Jordan's already regretting being on the
show I knew it would be this
uncomfortable
what about you gotta what's your best
movement like
if you're going to close this date do
you have like your number one move
I don't know if I have a number one move
you like kickflip or something
what his move is what's my move
that's true what's his best move what's
my best move
whoa
so you just that's hot yeah it's kind of
a jump you're like my best move is
kissing her so yeah how do you [ __ ]
go for it yeah man yeah just go for it
just do it that's awesome looking at his
lips now
that's cool you got nice lips
um what uh what do you try to do how do
you what are you thinking about when
you're kissing a [ __ ]
so if I put that much stuff a bit it's
very not [ __ ] a [ __ ]
kissing her yeah it's the next [ __ ]
no lift it off
here let me see
the switch is on hello
hello Mike is not on it's turned off
per usual it's not wow what a gentleman
yeah it's never the woman's fault
the woman is turned off Men start uh
kissing him
kissing him like Howard
Howard the kisser
um he's a good guesser why are you a
good guesser what do you show us with
your mouth
show us with your mouth show me yeah
well I don't know maybe I'd practice on
my hand when I show us on Nick Roche
whoa you just ate it like it was uh
Daniel's cannoli
I did have some of Daniels cannoli
how did Daniel's cannoli taste it was
amazing
nice
okay
there was just a strange man on stage
and Howard he did nothing to defend your
date no
from Boston she can defend herself right
yeah very self-sufficient
have you ever gotten into a fight
grab the mic and
describe a fight
what kind of fight like hair pulling
name calling no I'm a lady
it might be a mass hole but a masshole
lady yeah so you're pretty much more man
than Howard is
didn't go that far I don't surf
wow
Howard she just called you gay
he's okay with it
uh so yeah that's cool Howard uh how old
are you I am 39 years old wow what a
feels old saying what a distinguished
older gentleman he's a silver fox
getting there
that's hot
you're almost
AK-47 AK
so does that stand for something it does
okay your full name don't tell us your
full name like the first and last name
is your initials
AK no oh what does it stand for my first
name is akvela oh akavela a common
Boston name
full of akvelas where are you from what
ethnicity is that name from I'm
originally from
I was gonna guess Lithuania right after
Luxembourg for sure
where are you from uh Howard San Antonio
well like ethnically uh English I think
oh hell yeah I was just there yeah
saw a lot of you types over there just
surfing
surfing
great English English servers in the
channel yep yeah could be
anyways what kind of fights have you
been into because you're like what
defines a fight so what
have you done
in a verbal fight once or twice
so you called someone a [ __ ] or
something like that is that what
happened you can't yeah why'd you pack
your car there no I'm a big fan of you
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's awesome where in Massachusetts
are you from
I grew up in Southie Southie hell yes
went to school with Mark Wahlberg Almost
Do You Really poke a Vietnam Vietnamese
man's eye out
can't confirm or deny
okay I can't deny them can't deny that
you guys are crazy over there uh Howard
uh thank you for being on the show thank
you all for having me any advice for
anyone Visiting San Antonio no besides
away from the Riverwalk that's my
favorite part
I don't know
not a big San Antonio fan
he's just from there just from there
yeah not a good not a lot of good waves
on the Riverwalk no
well you know I don't think it's going
to work out between them yeah you guys
seem like you guys are already in
relationships
who wants to see uh AK going on a live
date on stage with their hinge day Zach
I do yes yes why don't we see that
Howard thank you so much for being on
the show Howard he's gonna go to his
successful relationship man yeah Zach
please make your way to the center stage
Zach
he's got abs of steel and a beard to
match
trying to make him sound like a stripper
Zach to the center stage going on a date
with his hinge date AK give it up for
Zach ladies and gentlemen
totally planned this
starting now
you have gorgeous eyes thank you so much
I love your earrings yeah you can just
compliment me the whole time we could do
that yeah maybe we can have a deeper
conversation you like but I got a minute
worth of compliments for sure
why did you swipe right on my profile
it's pretty easy okay
the oh God
you had some good jokes you were funny
thanks do you think I'm funny tonight or
maybe another cocktail and we'll find
out we've had plenty we had three okay
so clearly I'm the lightweight in this
relationship good to know I did say I'm
from Eastern Europe so well you kind of
lied actually you said you're from
Boston so now it's awkward for the whole
audience I said
again so
so can I get a ruling did she say she
was from or did she say she grew up in
Boston
and time
Zach is getting heckled on his hitch day
you're right you're definitely right
you're definitely right I screwed up I
got nervous he's a film critic you could
tell by his haircut
he's got a lot of notes for Zack Snyder
on his
hell yeah
so how is uh
how how is the hinge going for you go on
a lot of dates with a lot of a lot of
women this is the third one today but
it's the best one today oh wow I'm
kidding this is my first yeah it's
sarcasm come on
he's a jokester can't wait to cry in the
bathroom same it's gonna be great you
guys are together hold each other's hair
back I can't wait so AKA uh what do you
what do you think about Zach's uh
queries and questions on this date
they're pretty good yeah what what do
you guys talk about before you got on
stage
yeah one of the things was the
percentage of her getting on stage
zero yeah it was very high there's only
three other women but she wasn't gonna
put her name in but she's here for the
crowd
you're welcome thank you you guys are
now a crucial part of the show
give it up for this wonderful couple
I'm making money off of them on YouTube
as we speak like is is there a contract
for the percentage or is it actually
live streamed because I'm kind of hyped
if it is yeah it's live streams any
shout outs you like to give to your
other hinge dates love you Mom okay he
went on a hinge day with his mom my
mom's doing my best to enjoyed so far
actually greatest profile for sure your
mom helps you on your hinge profile my
mom made my hinge profile
he's a mama's boy what was so funny
explains all those aspects on this hinge
program your mom's an ass man
laughs
uh what was so funny about uh Zach's
profile
she had really good
such as
um big test here I
go because I showed like seven friends
before I came here to make sure he's not
a serial killer
um
one of them was silence your phone you
dumb [ __ ]
this is 20 22.
um one of his prompts was the key to my
heart is lost call if you find it and
that's what I liked and that's what
started our conversation
this is one of those gay dates yeah
that's gay as [ __ ] dude
I got a big heart dude sorry wow I can't
find it though big man with the Heart of
Gold where did you lose your heart do
you think like what age now you have to
give them the answer you gave me do you
remember that I don't actually that was
pretty funny too if you tell me I might
want to [ __ ] you so be careful play with
my heart yeah get in line dude and if
you don't tell him I may want to [ __ ]
you
get in line
or
what was the answer I don't I really
don't remember I don't know either way
you're getting [ __ ] you said I have a
really big heart so it's probably in a
large place like a stadium or a barn
yeah no you said in my heart's really
sweet so it's probably in a candy shop
somewhere
and then you said it's a very giving
heart
so it's probably paying for a nigerian's
prince vacation
I do remember this now I think again
told seven friends just in case he was a
serial killer we still have not
confirmed or denied I think he has
diabetes I will share my location with
everybody
okay okay
you're putting yourself out there the
internet's gonna find you and uh that's
good good you're being vulnerable that's
a good key part of a date uh what what
did uh what did ak's date or hinge
profile say anything that you remember
about her profile
um I remember her cute dog and the eyes
I haven't got that complimented yet but
that was definitely a big part of it for
sure
uh you are gay
oh my God that's my type calm down
my eyes and dogs do you mean tits and
ass
I mean yeah yeah for sure I was kind of
hoping yeah for that hell yeah yeah you
got to be direct man just feel like got
great ass
okay uh you have a great ass thank you
so much thanks for the coaching
I did my part for these was there a
photo on his profile because I know all
guys they're hinge profiled no one
there's never like a perfect one it's
always like these are good and then what
the [ __ ] is this what was his I don't
know about this one for in terms of
photos
it was the back of his head in front of
a pyramid
that's that's all yeah it's it's a it's
a double Flex because it's showing that
like I've been to the pyramids and then
second that like I can handle deep
thought I'm pondering a lot of [ __ ] at
that time I took it as he has a full
head of hair which is always a plus
I mean you can't see the front hairline
so I feel like that's a poor assessment
and you got some unbelievable it's
really funny to be making your hinge
profile and be like [ __ ] pyramid
it's gonna crush it dude it's one of the
wonders of the world
next up Taj Mahal
that'll get girls wet yeah yeah all
right I'll change it God what are you
gonna change it to yeah it works don't
change it probably a picture of my mom
a picture of you're the weird mom like
me and my mom just hugging it out
because they need if I'm a mama's boy I
gotta show it off apparently
yeah it's a red flag
okay JK
JK AK
JK 47.
so uh yeah Zach what uh what what are
you guys gonna do after this dating show
uh we took an edible earlier so we'll
see how that looks
which direction it's gonna lead I hope
it's I hope it goes well see has it
kicked in yeah no I I literally said
when we took I was like I really hope
that it hits after the show because I
didn't want to get up here and then like
not be able to speak
that would have been awkward for
everybody it would have been like Howard
was back up here
you guys are going to be uh
kissing not like Howard
maybe I was hoping that maybe Howard and
I could have a chat after the show yeah
I would I just want to know he could
teach you with his lips lots of tongue
not much tongue like
real handsy a lot of great help
[Laughter]
just help that should be your hinge
profile help
amount of questions he just had also
please help him please
I'm looking for my Howard
aren't we all just looking for our own
Howard
so yeah that's cool you guys maybe uh
maybe you guys could go to uh Sixth
Street go homeless watching
go feed the Homeless yeah that's like
more of a third date I think yeah maybe
fourth but we'll get there I hear if you
do that once you get a free pass for the
rest of the year to do that that's kind
of cool yeah they have little dispensers
Disneyland joke no one likes what is a
dispense
a little uh crack cocaine vials is it
like an advent calendar and you
yeah Advent calendar she's not Jewish
that's good are you Jewish lack no what
are you racially uh I would say white
racially with three religion I would say
I'm an atheist
oh you're racially an atheist yes
who knew he's a redditor
laughs
what's your Reddit profile username I
don't have a Reddit okay you just have
that haircut and Atheism
that's a good thing for your hinge
profile no Reddit okay not on Reddit
yeah only for Chan for Zach big 4chan
guy huge I'm joking just in case we're
going to be where were you on January
6th very Capital question
oh yeah supporting our country
but he stole our election uh AKA are you
vaccinated I am
I am oh
how does that make you feel Zach I mean
as a 4chan guy that was at the Capitol
it's kind of a problem but I am also
vaccinated and I wasn't at the Capitol
what I've never been unfortunate moderna
or Pfizer Pfizer moderna you should post
a photo of behind your Capital Camp I'm
getting sick for sure Jordan just said
you should post a picture of you at the
capitol of the back of your head at the
Capitol just pondering things and then
she'll be like he's got a full head of
hair yeah you see the bag of his hair so
he's got all of it
well that's hot you guys are definitely
gonna [ __ ] tonight uh please tag Us in
the story uh other people comedy do you
do stories when you have sex yeah is
that what youths are doing well he said
I gotta put on my story and I don't know
I hope that you can capture it all in 15
seconds
it's your first time so it's funny
yeah it's comical just the back of your
head going down on AK
full head of hair oh yeah hair on hair
action I don't know what her Bush
situation is
but uh yeah give it up for
you know give it up for this hinge date
Zach and AK we're taking credit for it
[ __ ] hinge
[Music]
let's go into the lgbtqia plus bucket
it's either two frat dudes that are
around
or a member of the actual community over
there on 4th Street we got Ellis and
Chris the two gays that signed up
are they really gay one of them is not
even a gay man but a woman
so hopefully
hopefully someone switches
I thought Chris was a man's name
[Music]
she's already uh requiring gentlemanly
assistance from a gay man
Ellis and Chris one minute starting now
[Music]
so uh I'm I'm Ellis I'm Chris all right
we uh
I saw your grinder grinder profile and
yes I mean that's how I get all the men
yeah is through my grinder profile yeah
yeah
and uh it shows my big dicks yeah and
um
never shows the boobs so it's it's a
little misleading what about the whole
picks
absolutely not a game now
[Laughter]
oh my God I am so uncomfortable I want
to die right now
a little uncom a discomfort I fell over
something in the back of the stage on
the way over here
was it my heart yeah it was
so they just said lgbtq plus they didn't
specify so that's that's how this
happened okay uh I identify as a gay man
okay if that's what you're asking
I identify as a lesbian however I dig
guys a lot so I don't think it really
counts well that's the Plus
and time give it up for Ellis and Chris
uh so weird that she feels uncomfortable
after he after he talked about whole
pics
[Laughter]
an HP is that a common phrase in the gay
community hey send me some of them whole
pics whole whole pics absolutely HP is
something else feel that Patrick
Harry Potter no but I really want to
know what that is so can you tell me
later
horsepower
[Laughter]
a whole pick or HP what does HP stand
for
HPV is is something that we all know
about but uh
that had HPV yeah that's in the straight
Community too yeah
yeah it's a crossover I think it's an I
think it's an everybody thing I didn't
know
or deep down deep down we all have STDs
something we could bond over I did not
know that uh no but a whole pick is like
a difference I am guessing I know what
that is so do you know what a top and a
bottom is yeah okay so a bottom will
send whereas the top will send a picture
of his dick uh his or her his or her I'm
trying to be politically correct yeah
where lgbtq plus plus
there's all these pluses minus divided
you have to walk on eggshells when you
talk exponential and so but a bottom and
oftentimes instead of saying hello we'll
just send a pic of his hole
um which hole
butthole wow it is interesting it is
interesting that it can really only mean
one hole Yeah
okay you're not sending pics of your pee
hole no no I know that really big and
then you're like check out how big my
pee hole is look what you can fit in
here it's not even a sexual thing it's
like check this [ __ ] out dude this is
wild
that's just medically concerning yeah
I thought when you said whole pig you
made pictures of Shia LaBeouf
holes picks that's whole sex
[Music]
no uh yeah
Stanley yeah can I make a complaint
right now of like all of the straight
people who have anal sex that do it
wrong whoa lesbian lessons anal sex from
lesbians let's hear about it first of
all like um gay men know this but you
need to clean the back end out before
you not if you want to have a good time
she's like guys
[Laughter]
I mean there's different ways to do it
yeah but you'll at least have the
consideration to do it in advance
that's uh but I mean sometimes you're
just kind of on you know it's a you want
a Whimsical thought do you want to hang
out with Dan Savage because I've got
some we
work I would love to hang out with Dan
Savage
dude this is by far the best
Dan Savage if you're watching we would
love to hang out with you
send me your head
I don't know if his husband will allow
it uh [ __ ] it damn Savage still take
your whole pig
this is the most chemistry and you guys
don't even know I don't know where to
hear it anymore they're just hanging out
we're
absolutely hopefully his moped fits in
your Subaru
[Laughter]
hell yeah first Applause Break Of The
Night
cats because I really don't like them
I'm like always convinced they're gonna
like try to attack my toes and I don't
know why he doesn't like cats I don't
like cats
you know a lot about anal sex to attack
on my toes and I don't know where that
comes from but it's a really awkward
fear of mine I don't have any cats but I
do like toes oh
put him in his hole the only
thing the only thing we
can you guys both have them or are you
into feet
no we both have them
you're not into feet no but I could
change my mind really quick if it would
please the crowd because I'm really
uncomfortable right now who wants her to
be into pee right now
what is something that you're into
genuinely
like seriously puzzles
I love that I like paddle boarding
you are from Austin yeah I live I'm from
I'm actually from here I'm a unicorn
because I'm from Austin yeah and you
love paddle boarding and I love paddle
boarding
you love bird scooters no no scooters I
wreck those too many times Topo Chico uh
yeah we've got a lot of trouble chica at
my house but only because it mixed
really well with vodka who do you live
with
uh I have a roommate is it a cat no I've
got a dog and a alcoholic for a roommate
it's the same person it's a dog
no the dog's name Ellie the alcoholics
named Kevin
I don't think this is a human being no
no alcoholic for a roommate
what's the craziest thing that your
alcoholic roommate's done you don't want
to hear
[Music]
do you have any Hole pics you want to
show us no but damn it's close because
it's really good is he straight no that
whole picture gross see that's why
that'll be cute it doesn't offend me
there they can be a little aggressive in
them singing yeah
they don't always clean down there
that's really uh she's so courteous to
be like not that whole pics are gross
they are gross he's calling them whole
picks dude
wait is our one minute date over because
I'm freaking out a little bit you're
doing great should we ask uh Ellis some
questions yes what do you what do you
want to know if that's jail in his hair
is that come oh no I want to know if I
can touch it
you wanna you can touch it
wow
it's like um one of those modeling clays
oh
come and am I right
yes and I'm right all right wow does it
make you more comfortable when you touch
my hair yeah kinda okay you can touch it
you can touch it whenever you make it
okay if it calms you down this dress
relief no I'm autistic so textures help
okay yeah I kind of also wanted to see
if your shirt felt cool but it turns out
it doesn't
she she just roasted you bro no I did
she said your shirt sucks
that's a read I think Alice is now
officially a lesbian
oh my God me and Alice later
yes do you know how amazing that is
scissors anybody tried it scissoring
well that's when two bottoms get
together and
yeah
no scissoring's awesome okay scissor me
timbers
[Laughter]
straight guys so y'all have like no clue
yeah we don't have all of y'all have
ever seen this corn which actually
doesn't it doesn't work
yeah that's it's hard to take a dick pic
when you're scissoring or a whole pic
straight guy still scissor with each
other
okay
you want people to Heckle you yeah
yeah who wants to Heckle Chris I wanted
to hear what they had to say
they wanted to give you scissoring tips
maybe hopefully do you clean down there
before you scissor or do you just raw
dog
a guy
he's going to the library she's cleaning
down there yeah
anything clean but when it's two girls
okay so how scissoring works for those
of you who don't know because I'm
guessing that's most of you yeah break
it down
um
is you put like both of your clits
together and then you rub back and forth
and then you have orgasms I I wow
it's quite amazing you're kind of
turning me into a lesbian see
it's
it's oh I think they just scissors
that's hot I'll have to watch some
videos about this I'll have to do some
research when I get home you say yeah
accurate there's like no lesbian porn
that's made by lesbians
leather jackets that we should create I
know right I could be making a lot of
money right now yeah maybe you could
sell some hole on hold me and the
pointer though I would have to like hire
other people to be an appointment
director you'd be you're saying he'd be
a great director
yeah I have a question when you're
seeing two girls scissor and porn and
you're like they're [ __ ] this up
don't see them
because you can't get
it I love it
I can just show you about a million
search results I have on my phone the
new GoPros are pretty small
maybe I'm looking in the wrong places
but I'm pretty sure I've given
there so it's the angle it's the angle
that's the problem
yeah they can't get a good
camera angle on a good scissor you want
to see the clits smashing against each
other smash yes yeah that's what I
wanted I needed a GoPro inside of a
vagina yeah yeah okay I mean he has
whole picks all I want to see is close
[ __ ] smashing together so that's less
gross than a whole kick I'll tell you
that
and you said you have autism yes I am
autistic this is weird which is why
that's why I wasn't gonna
try I'm doing great he's doing great
you're doing great Chris
[Applause]
Oh Yes actually okay
I'm not messing your hair trust me
oh he lets me pet his head for
relaxation I'm actually okay with that
so I feel like there's a friend future
for us yes
Scissor Sisters
and I love that band yeah
you love that band
two sisters wow this is the closest
anyone's come to [ __ ] off the stage
all right play that music DJ
is this what you're thinking about I
don't think they can censor to this
is very slow
Ellis you got any tips on how to have
good anal sex for all these yes do you
I'm curious uh for the streets well
administrates
um
clean it out first
like Alice doesn't seem to be down the
streets don't do that I like an imprint
to [ __ ] as well but true that's true I
mean just keep it clean generally eat a
lot of salad and wash your whole uh use
use a Toto
it's it's a it's a toilet that little
spray oh a bidet oh yeah I mean like so
if you do that routine I don't know uh
[Laughter]
there's also like yeah there's cleaning
out mechanisms but uh
uh so silicone lube is better than a
water-based lube for anal sex what about
the lube
that's so American silicone lube so look
no it's way better than uh than
water-based lube for anals what about
Lube that has wheat in it
I don't think so no okay because I'm
also allergic to like everything so okay
the silicone base so latex no I'm
allergic to latex okay so how packing it
is
give it up for Chris and Ellis
the lgbtqia plus bucket
Works its magic again wow we really
don't know anything about that Community
we just sort of put that bucket out
there like the
like the Jews during Passover with
Elijah
uh but we got one more woman we saved
the best for last
we got Natasha
to the center stage
here she comes
going on a date with Jorge
goodness
oh there they came together
we're gonna watch them
[Music]
Ellis is a token gay guy of this group
give it up for Jorge and Natasha they
came together
well hello
hi nice to meet you you made me walk two
and a half miles with sushi in my hands
but I'm glad I'm here
foreign
okay so tell me about you what what are
your interests what are your goals what
do you want to do in life
your eyes are so beautiful
thank you thank you so are yours oh stop
uh my goals in life well
I I love dance okay I teach Zumba that
sounds fun I love Latin dance even
though I look white I can dance I I I'm
really excited to see how that goes yeah
you there was a there's a third question
to that what was uh dream goals and
hobbies uh dream goals to become an
avian vet interesting so you do you have
any pets that you like specifically yeah
I have five Birds oh [ __ ]
um so like do you use them for food or
are they kind of like left in a corner
and they just like are really loud end
time give it up for Jorge and Natasha
Jorge thinks that you have chickens in
your in your front yard like you're in
uh like you're in the projects or
something it's a common piece of
conversation we have it's a big
conversation that we have all about your
birds you guys look like you ripped your
clothes off of a cushion in the East
yeah they have the same fabric dealer
I got out of errands so
a couple that shops together stays
together that's right this guy is driven
they eventually start
ripping and confidence Jorge are you a
lot easier what where does your
confidence come from your clean [ __ ]
yeah is it the name I douche I make sure
to douche always you douche what a
douche
how do you what is a douche I've never
actually seen a spray though
yeah kind of like that okay she's into
it so I got it kind of how long have you
guys been together
two years wow so this is a long
established couple
how did you guys meet hinge hey it works
isn't that an awesome company
is it I don't know or is that bumble
anyways so so you had that line about
eating the birds ready to go
he likes to do stand-up comedy so he's
thriving in the spotlight
yeah making a lot of money doing
stand-up comedy what do you do besides
stand-up comedy uh I'm a test engineer
for a DOD company so you test if you can
be an engineer or yeah basically you
like do crash test dummies I do cry
there's some crashes know me to deal
with what's DOD Department of Defense
Yeah so basically I build things for
aircrafts to detect enemies from other
countries
well thank you for your service
thank you for killing all those Russians
that's right he has um way too good of a
job to make it at stand-up comedy yes
you hear that sometimes some people like
I'm doing comedy I just bought a house
it's like you'll never make it you're
[ __ ] you're [ __ ]
so do you guys you don't live together
we do yeah oh so you're familiar with
the birds
of course
quite familiar with the birds they are
the epitome of my existence I love them
so much what are their names
lemon kiwi figgy Juniper ametrine and
the what was the other one there's
another one is that all of them that's
all of them for no
that's hilarious you know that's he
thought they were more than there
actually were it's my brains [ __ ]
are they loud do they they can be are
the worst things I've ever experienced
no they're not whoa okay if you're about
to like be so harsh on them no I love
them they're they're they they're keep
us
he loves them he loves the birds with
honey mustard I also like going to
Pluckers too so I kind of like pick and
choose my battles that's good what
what's uh what's something that you get
away with because she has Birds that's a
good question yeah sure I can't get away
with a lot of things with her tattoos no
I told her from the get-go if you don't
like tattoos get the [ __ ] out I like
tattoos
awesome you guys are gonna [ __ ] for sure
that's hot
oh it's monthly so it's Shark Week I
don't know about that
what the birds are chirping away at you
oh my God it doesn't [ __ ] during Shark
Week
you need you need to tell it this is
because you need to be so concentrated
you need to tell them about the time oh
[ __ ] yeah there was a time in the living
room during Shark Week
um where we were going on our business
and the the devil evil [ __ ] green bird
jumped on my ass and bit the creek of my
ass and I just [ __ ] screamed
it was the it was the funniest thing it
was because like I think our neighbors
heard us and they were concerned
yeah they're like there's six Birds over
there it's just sort of high-pitched
Yelp or like the time that we're just
going about our business and the birds
are in the room and they speak human
words
um so they say what a good boy yeah
so they're being condescending to your
boyfriend and that's why
it was it's perfect for them to do that
when he does the dishes and stuff the
birds are like what a good boy it's
reinforcement that I don't have to do
so what kind of freaky things do you
guys get into in the bedroom
it's fun besides Bird play we do a lot
of like
um like uh patient Dr roleplay but
probably she's a vet so I gotta pretend
like I'm a dog and she sticks her finger
in my ass
that was a bit hopefully you have a good
day
you let him write does he does she do
that thing that the Disney princesses do
where she goes like this and the birds
take her clothes off and then they [ __ ]
them
we can work on it
over time yeah
yeah that's cool so hinged two years ago
during the pandemic you were like [ __ ]
fouchy I gotta [ __ ] that's right
the sushi thing was real she made me
walk two and a half miles with sushi and
drinks just the meter because she had no
and sand on a beach yes
what where did you guys meet what city
California Main California oh and then
you moved here no no we moved from
Indiana calm down
yeah we went from it we we went from LA
to Indiana Indiana to here we're from
everywhere yeah wow yeah it looks like
you guys live in a van
what what what what uh what got you to
Indiana why were you guys in Indiana my
job you're a vet yeah I'm working on
specialty which is really hard to get
positions and it's really competitive so
I matched with the hospital in Indiana
and we had no other choice but to go
nice you match with a job you match with
a boyfriend yeah yeah you get your job
at the same place kind of interesting so
you want to be a a vet I am a visit and
I'm getting a kind of a hippie sort of
vibe and you make Weaponry
for the Department of Defense right
which if this is live I might get in
trouble so yeah well don't say anything
more but
what uh what branch of the and what are
the codes no no no no
7642 we
um we sell to everybody very short code
yeah
we sold everybody
it's all to internet International we
sell to any mil any military
any military we're the U.S government we
make Weaponry we'll sell to anybody
doesn't matter who you are
that's good Russia or Ukraine some lady
with birds what kind of weapon you want
I know all the secrets
that's cool you work for the Department
of Defense and you moved from California
to India anybody
very low standards this military
what's what's the craziest person that
you sold weapons to
is above my security clearance but uh I
ran Iran this guy sold the weapons so I
ran nice which side
I can't say yeah
telling us which side
he saw the the people that uh killed
Masa amini hashtag masamini once again
she's taking care of sick Birds he's
selling weapons they really better
currently killing Freedom Fighters Iran
they really hate people she's like I'd
rather help animals and he's like I'd
rather kill people it's so true well
it's not killing animals he's killing
it's it kind of works actually yeah
we sound like a good match yeah it feels
like it feels like a good like trade-off
like she saves I kill you know balance
she sees one of his drones hit a bird
and he's like my girlfriend's not gonna
like this
devastating yeah
that's awesome this is like very unique
jobs for a couple I never thought a vet
and a merchant of death would meet
van lifing together
[ __ ] cool where do you guys live an
apartment a house
we have an apartment up in Sunset
apartment in Sunset with five Birds dude
neighbors ever complain no but you have
a massive dog that lives above this dog
like a giant dog this dog is like eight
dollars 180 pounds it Stomps at like
eight o'clock eight o'clock at night
and sometimes I just want to get up
there and like give it value and just to
[ __ ] put it out
okay let's change the term that we just
used there put it down excuse me let's
take a step back this is a no-kill uh
vet and an all-kill
oh yeah
I have a question you said your
complaint about the dog is not that it's
barking it's that it's stopping it's
Extremely Loud it is very very loud you
hear it run I think it might be a person
I don't know I mean they're they're a
little bigger but I don't I don't I
don't think that's no it's not like them
they're dogs like at least 175 pounds
damn full human
so it's like a Great Dane yeah okay yeah
what would you recommend as a vet
above us
sedatives
we can we could script some Gatherings
euthanasia no okay how about this
by its slippers
Target that's not a bad idea get us some
Jordans
yeah some sort of cushiony sneaker yeah
Stop The Stomping or just like put like
some uh mats down on their floor yeah
what a few bottom mats
I don't know a lot of animals in your
life how do you like Austin it seems
like the city was made specifically for
you guys no uh we got an ax Austin's
been rough but Austin's been a little
bit rough for us personally yeah we we
moved here in five days and we I got
into a car accident totaled my car
injured both of us not at fault
um after that my car got broken into
yeah and vandalized and then his car got
towed in the city
I think that was like our three out of
three yeah I'm hoping it's gonna be so
much better now well everyone's gotten
towed here so that's not a big deal but
yeah a car accident is pretty pretty
scary
um
so you weren't at fault no
okay I don't believe you I I'm happy I'm
not because my insurance is paying for
everything awesome
yeah I believe her I was driving here
just on the other Street and I looked to
my side and there was a guy who made eye
contact with me and he was drinking
Hennessy
and then just kept driving in his
[ __ ] car Austin dude okay you didn't
have to be so racial with the Hennessy
man but he was white though right he was
white what was he driving a Lincoln
Navigator
I'm just kidding it was uh it was uh you
know what
never mind
yeah I mean um
cops are defunded uh I think they're
they're kind of on a working strike I
don't think anyone's really looking out
for the roads and they don't really pave
them either a lot of a lot of uh
potholes yeah not compared to Indy but
there's potholes here yeah I mean
anything's better than Indiana this is
so true yeah so accurate so that's
that's crazy but I mean at least you
know there's a good stand-up Community
here he's trying to do stand-up comedy
to assuage his guilt for killing
innocent people
this is a good place for that it helps
so you think of therapy therapy yeah
they're therapy Birds [ __ ] those birds
just kidding I love them it's like um
I love that the most serious arguments
they're having in the relationship are
about birds
it's like marriage story but the issue
is
these [ __ ] Birds
it should be worse
what could be worse
we could have legitimate problems I
think what you need is to get your own
animals I do I have a dog for Birds a
guy like cats you know
if you gotta you gotta fight the birds
uh you know it's better
ferrets ferrets are better [ __ ] up those
birds yeah they will
it'll be like a cutest race
which you're familiar with that's right
uh yeah so you'd get ferrets you would
get a dog to kill the ferret you would
get a [ __ ] I don't know a tiger
it'd just be a never-ending I think
that's actually legal in Texas yeah hell
yeah welcome to Texas yeah
you won't have a car but you will have a
tiger I've seen it in Indy oh nice
um yeah any questions for this uh
uh sorry we're so boring you're very
interesting actually it's very
interesting
um
you guys are like a Wes Anderson couple
oh that means but okay
Steve's azuzu quirky yeah magic quirky
oh yeah I got nothing
yeah you guys are great thank you for
being on the show appreciate it thank
you
we happen to pull them out they're
already a couple
is 100 success rate for the last couple
of the night
that was the show thank you guys so much
for coming out Jordan Shelby you can
find him on drunkest wipe drunk white
boy on Instagram very funny comedian
please check him out we're gonna be
touring in California soon Irvine Oxnard
San Jose other places uh thank you for
this table for coming out
they were just there they didn't say
much but they were entertaining
nonetheless
they're all [ __ ] each other
um thank you my name is Hans Kim DJ on
skin thank you guys good night drive
safe
hope especially YouTube